d'un côté alexandre lukashenko se veut
facilitateur en accueillant sur son
territoire les pourparlers entre les
délégations et demi de l'autre son pays
sert de base arrière à la russie c'est
depuis ce territoire que moscou a lancé
son offensive sur kiev
mardi alexandre loukachenko a annoncé le
déploiement de troupes supplémentaires
biélorusse à la frontière avec l'ukraine
et demandé à vladimir poutine de
déployer davantage de missiles à l'ouest
du pays pourtant nous cacher nicolas
firme cette mesure est seulement
défensive
nous ne sommes pas en guerre contre eux
il n'y a pas besoin de ça pas besoin du
tout aucun missile ne vole là-bas depuis
notre territoire il n'y a pas besoin de
cela mais la chef de l'opposition
biélorusse réfugiés en lituanie dénonce
le rôle de la biélorussie et appelle à
une mobilisation anti guerre dans un
pays c'est de nos aérodrome que les
avions décollent et larguent des bombes
sur jitomir des roquettes sont lancés
depuis nos champs sur tchernigov des
centaines de chars entrent chaque jour
en ukraine par nos passages frontaliers
alors à quoi joue le président
biélorusse au pouvoir depuis 1994
loukachenko a longtemps entretenu des
relations complexes avec moscou mais
c'est grâce à l'appui du kremlin qu'il a
pu se maintenir au pouvoir malgré la
contestation massive contre sa
réélection truquée en 2020 depuis le
pays n'est plus qu'un bas salle de
moscou ultra dépendant de son soutien
économique politique et militaire
dimanche la biélorussie a renoncé à son
statut de neutralité nucléaire via un
référendum critiqué avec une crainte
désormais chez les occidentaux que ce
pays puisse servir de rampe de lancement
de missiles nucléaires à la russie